[Müzik]
herkese merhaba bugün burada böyle güzel
bir Hıdır lez gününde bereketin yağdığı
günde yine yağmurla karşılandık ve çok
mutluyum ki bu güzel yıllarımı
geçirdiğim okulumda sizlerle
bugün iklim krizini konuşacağız ve iklim
krizi biliyorsunuz artık bilim insanları
IPS raporları hepsi söylüyor ki dünyanın
karşısındaki insanlığın karşısındaki en
ciddi kriz daha önce 15 yıl önce belki
10 yıl öncesine baktığımızda hepimizin
aklında Kutup ayılarıyla
Belki buzullarla canlanıyordu bu kriz
Evet bir yerde bir şeyler oluyordu Ama
bu bize çok uzaktı ve bizim hayatımızdan
çok uzaktı daha bizim hayatımızın
etkilemesine de çok vardı ama 2-3 sene
önce hepimiz Özellikle de Türkiye'de
orman yangınlarıyla dünyanın Binbir
çeşiti yerinde de farklı farklı
kasırgalarla sellerle farklı olaylarla
iklim krizini hepimiz deneyimlemeye
başladık Ve şu an hepimiz farkındayız ki
Bu kriz Artık bizimle ben bu krizi ne
zaman
farkettim derseniz 12 yıl önce ben de
Tarım ve Gıda üzerine çalışmaya başladım
ve baktım ki
o yönde
Yüzyıllardır belki üretilen ürünler
artık üretilememeye başladı O ürünlerin
hasatları hiçbir zaman bir hafta bile
sapmayan hasatlar artık aylar sapıyordu
ve Anadolu coğrafyasında biliniyordu bir
şey var yani bir meteorolojik bir şey
var ve bir şeyler değişiyor Ama bu kadar
ciddi olduğunu ben de bu işe girince
fark ettim ve onun Sonrasında da
Yaklaşık 10 yıl önce hamile kaldım ve 9
yıl önce de anne oldum anne olmamla
Tabii ki bu konuda duyduğum endişe çok
daha değişti ama her şeyden önce
Hepsinin başına gitmek istiyorum ben
bunlara nasıl bu endişeyi duyacak hale
geldim Aslında her şey hepimizin
çocukluğuna dayanıyor Ben de çocukluğuma
baktığımda aranızda eminim küçük şehirde
yaşamış insanlar vardır küçük şehirden
İstanbul'a gelmiş insanlar vardır Ben de
İstanbul nazaran çok daha küçük bir
şehirde Yaşadım ve Aslında oranın
avantajlarının da hayatıma çok etkisi
olduğunu ve beni şekillendiren şeyler
olduğunu da daha sonra çok daha fark
ettim Neydi bu avantajlar küçük şehirde
yaşayan insanlar aslında çok daha
güvenli bir ortamda yaşıyorlar Bizler
çok daha Doğa içinde yaşıyoruz küçük
şehirde Doğa lüks değildir Çünkü doğal
sizin hayatınızdadır şehriniz yeterince
bina içinde
kaplanmamıştır sokaklarınız yemyeşildir
birkaç Belki bir 15 dakika yürüyüşle
zaten kırlara erişirsiniz O yüzden çok
şanslıyım ki doğada geçirdiğim bir
Çocukluğum oldu 5 dakika içerisinde
trafikte yoktur ve 5 dakika içerisinde
ailenin büyüklerine hızlıca ulaşırsınız
ve onlara dinlemek için çok uzun
zamanınız vardır çünkü başka kaybedecek
zamanlarınız yoktur birçok şeyi
yaparsanız çok küçük yaşta Ben şu an
çocuklarımın yaptığını Hayal edemediğim
şeyleri ben belki 4-5 yaşında sokakta
gidip kendi kendime Hani bakkala gitmek
kasaba gitmek şuna gitmek buna gitmek
Bunlar bizim için çok kolay şeylerdi ve
bunlar ne getiriyor bunlar aslında
sorumluluk getiriyor ve
keşfedebiliyorsunuz Meraklı
olabiliyorsunuz merak ne getirir merak
Tutku getirir ve ben birçok şeyi buradan
aldığımı düşünüyorum ve Bence küçük
şehirin en önemli şeyi de birbirine
herkes tanır Herkes birbirinin
sorunununu bilir ve buna bireysel olarak
sessizce yardım eder Eğer ki birinin
büyük bir sorunu varsa hep birlikte
oluruz yardım ederiz
sivil toplum aslında küçük şehirlerde
hayatımızı doğal akışıdır Bu yüzden de
çok mutluyum ki Tekirdağ'da büyüdüm
sonrasında İstanbul'a geldim ama Bir de
nedir şekillendiren bizleri ailemiz
çevremiz Aynı zamanda da Doğa aşığı ama
gerektiği yerde sesini de çok çıkaran
kadının güçlenmesi için çalışan doğada
kuşu görünce yeni bir kuş türü görünce
yeni bir ot görünce heyecanlanan anne
babayla büyüdü Bunlar benim en büyük
şanslarımdı Ve tabii ki hepimizin
genetik getirdiği özellikler de var
hepsi birbirimizin şansı
aklımda da hep bir lider vardı o zamanın
liderlerinden biraz daha farklıydı bu
Aklımdaki Lider bu Lider nasıl bir
liderdi bu Lider genelde kadın da
aslında o zamanlar o kadar çok kadın
Lider görmesek de ne Siyasette Ne iş
dünyasında benim kafamda canlanan bir
kadın vardı daha vicdanlı işler yapan
fazla toplumsal çevresel sorun varken
bunlardan birini ya da birkaçını kendine
dert edinen ve bu dert için İşinde de
çalışan hayatında da özel hayatında da
çalışan bunu kendi hayatının Misyonu
haline getiren
gerektiğinde ağlayan
gerektiğinde sarmalayan kırılganlığını
gösterebilen bir lider Şu an aslında
görüyoruz Bu liderleri Günden güne
herkes böyle değişmeye başladı çünkü Ne
oldu dünya değişiyor dünyada yaşamak
zorlaşıyor
Tosya ekonomik problemler şu an düşünün
etrafımızı sarmış durumda ve bize ne iyi
geliyor işte Yeni Zelanda'nın
başbakanına hatırlayın
onun o bebeği ile
sahneye çıktığını hatırlayın onun o
büyük patlamadan Sonra insanlara nasıl
kırıldığını nasıl ağladığını hatırlayın
bunları görmek bize iyi geliyor ya da
patagonya'nın başkanı ivon nasıl bir
adam hayatı boyunca bir şeyi Tutku
haline getirmiş Kero odaklı olmadan
böyle bir şirket kurmuş dünyanın en
büyük şirketlerinden birini kurmuş bunu
kâr maksimizasyonuna ve misyonuna adamış
ve şimdi geçen sene hepimiz onu konuştuk
bütün şirketinin hisselerini bir vakfa
verdi ve ne dedi artık
Patagonya açıkladı artık bizim
hissedenimiz dünyadır ben de işte Tam da
böyle tarımla
uğraştığımda dediğim gibi bunları
yaşamaya başladım ve esas burada bu
alarmı gördüm ve ne yapabilirim Dedim
acaba ben
bu kadar büyük bir kriz var Evet Herkes
bu krizde olmalı Herkes bu mücadeleye
katılmalı ama ben kıvılcım olarak ne
yapabilirim Bu kriz için
Tam da bunu düşünürken
Ben de
bilime kurak verdim Tabii ki Çünkü bilim
bunu söylüyor ve bilim olmadan bilimin
ışığında olmadan da bu mücadelede yer
alamıyorsunuz ben de işte lisansımı bu
okulda okumuştum ama daha matematik
üzerine bir lisansdı Bu da tabii ki bize
birçok Analitik düşünmeyi kattığı Fakat
benim bu konuda da bir lisansı okumam
gerekiyordu Bu konuda bir lisans okudum
dünyanın birçok Üniversitesinde çok
önemli üniversitelerde önemli
programları tamamladım Çünkü dünyanın
sesini dinlemek gerekiyordu küresel bir
kriz vardı ama en önemlisi çokça insan
tanıdım bir sürü
akademisyeni bir sürü bu konuda mücadele
eden sivil toplum gönüllüsüne alo dedim
sizinle Buluşabilir miyim dedim bu krizi
daha iyi dinlemek istiyorum sizden daha
farklı yönlerden dinlemek istiyorum
dedim gerçekten çok Okudum ve çok
dinledim ve burada ben de en iyi
yaptığım şeyle yer almak istedim Her
birimiz Aslında bu mücadelede bir
bakmamız lazım bize Neşe veren şey ne
ben ne yaptığımda mutlu oluyorum ve ben
hangi alanda iyiyim
ve Bu kriz için ne yapılması gerekiyor
Yani bu İster iklim krizi olsun ister
adaletsizlikler üzerine çalışın ister
yoksulluk üzerine çalışın bu harita net
ben biliyorum ki ben benden daha büyük
bir şey için çalışmaktan mutlu oluyorum
ve mutluluk bana böyle geldiğini
biliyorum Kendimden çok daha büyük bir
şey için Çalışmam gerekiyor Peki benim
en iyi yaptığım şey ne benim en iyi
yaptığım şey aslında
merakla bir şeyin peşinden koşmak onu
bir tutku haline getirmek bu konuda en
iyi çalışanlarla bir araya gelmek onları
birleştirmek büyük resmi görüp problemi
görmek ve o noktaları O insanları
birleştirmek Çünkü bu disiplinler arası
kriz Bu sadece mühendisin sadece bir
akademisyenin sadece bir hukukçunun
çözebileceği bir kriz değil ancak hep
beraber bir araya gelirsek şey
olabiliriz ve en önemlisi Bence benim
Bana iyi gelen özelliklerinden bir
tanesi
olmaz bu yapılmaz denilenin dinlememek
Çünkü tarih Hep bunlarla dolu
dinleyince hikaye değişmiyor oyun
değişmiyor başka bir yol gördüğünüzde ve
bu hikayeyi başka bir şekilde
anlatabilirim dediğinizde hikaye
değişiyor ve ben de olmaz denilene
inanıyorsan ve anlamına inanıyorsam bu
mücadeleyi etmeyi seviyorum
ve ben de böyle yaptım ve baktım ki
zaten bu konunun peşinde çok önemli
insanlar var ve Herkes bu konuda Az çok
benim çevremde bu zamandır çalıştığım
insanlar bu konuda mücadele etmek
istiyor ve hep beraber mücadele
edebileceğimiz gerçekten neslimizin
hikayesini değiştirmek üzere En azından
ülkemizde başlayıp bu Global krize
sonrasında Global şekilde hareket
edebileceğimiz
her kesime de farklı hikaye anlatıcılığı
yöntemiyle konuşacağımız bir şey
yapmalıydı ve biz bu şekilde yavaş yavaş
Yuvamız dünyamız için çalışmaya başladık
Peki bu kriz neydi
Biz biliyoruz ki Bu kriz çevresel bir
kriz değil
Bu kriz kültür krizi Bu kriz Biz sağlık
krizi bir sosyal kriz ekonomik kriz
çocuk hakları kadın hakları krize
bir hayal edin mangut Tayfun olduğu
2018'de mangut tayfını 250 kilometre ile
beraber
ilk önce filipinleri vurdu İki gün sonra
Hong kong'u vurdu hatırlıyor musunuz
Hong Kong 4 metre suları altında kaldı
bütün teknelerde dağıldı bütün etrafı
dağılmıştı fakat 18 sonra saat sonra
trenler çalışmaya başladı ve ertesi gün
okullar açılmıştı Peki Filipinler'de Ne
oldu Filipinler'de maalesef
hala ölümler Aylar geçse de hastalıklar
devam ediyordu 200'den fazla ölüm oldu
hükümet dedi ki Bu kriz öyle bir şey ki
bu Tayfun bir daha adını anmak
yasaklandı ama o Filipinler hiç bu
konuyu bu krize sebep olan ülke değildi
yaptıklarıyla bu krize sebep
olmamışlardı Ama büyük bir adaletsizlik
yaşadılar ya da düşünün 8 yaşında bir
çocuksunuz
Afrika'da yaşıyorsunuz ve birçok kişi
birçok futbolcu çıkartmış ülkenin sizin
de hayaliniz futbolcu olmak Çünkü o
futbolcular o ülkenin kahramanı
olmuşlardı Siz de bunu istiyorsunuz
biliyorsunuz yeteneklisiniz ama camı
açınca bile 45 derece hava sıcaklığı var
dışarıda oynayan tek bir arkadaşınız
size seslenen tek bir arkadaşınız yok Bu
kırılganlığı bir yaşayın bir düşünün
ya da başka bir senaryo herkesin
izlediği bir dizinin senaristi Sizsiniz
ve
sizin sayenizde birçok kişi sizin
verdiğiniz mesajlardan etkileniyor
çarşamba günleri kimseye Sizin diziniz
var diye oraya bir program koymuyor
çocuklar sınavlarını bir gün sonrasına
erteletiyor ama ya siz bu gücünüz bu
gücünüz varken yok o krizin ciddiyetini
bilip bunu kendi dizilerinize adapte
etseydiniz
tanıdık bir hikaye Ancak bu hikaye
Titanik'in önceki sesi gibi olmayacak
biliyorsunuz senik yine Yola çıkıyor
fakat başına daha önce gelen şey başına
şimdi gelmeyecek Çünkü artık orada o
derece bozuluyor artık Dünya çok değişti
zor günler bizi bekliyor Evet bu nedenle
iklim krizinin olacaklarını bilip yapıcı
bir endişeye kapılmamız gerekiyor çünkü
endişemiz olmasa da olmayınca da
maalesef aksiyona geçemiyoruz
2050 Eğer ki hiçbir şey yapmazsak bizi
bekleyenlerden sizi bahsedeceğim Eğer ki
bugün yaptığımız gibi davranırsak
2050-27 yıl sonra hiç uzakta değil
düşünebiliyor musunuz Ben şu an 38
yaşındayım işte 65 yaşında olacağım
kızım oğlum 7-9 yaşında onlar
hayatlarının en güzel zamanında olacak
ama eğer hiçbir şey yapmazsak artan
sıcaklıklar nem oranlarıyla her birimizi
çok daha fazla etkileyecek istediğimiz
zaman artık dışarı çıkamayacağız ve bu
sıcaklıklar bizim moralimizi bozacak
depresyona gireceğiz Belki çok daha
fazla birbirimize çatışmaya yaşayacağız
yaz aylarında Güney bölgelerde Hindistan
Afganistan gibi şey ülkelerde Sadece
insanlar gece 2 saat uyuyabilecekler
düşünülen iki saat uyuyabildiğinizi
huzurlu bir yaşam olur mu
herkes kitlesel göçlere başlayacak ve
ülkemizin de bu kitlesel göçlerden çok
etkileneceğini bilim insanları bize
söylüyor
şehirlerin artışı milyonlarca kişiyi
evinden şehrinden itecek ve Seller daha
fazla mantardan küften kaynaklı hastalık
yayacaklar
şiddetli Kasırga fırtınaları göreceğiz
bu hiç görmeyeceğimiz dediğimiz yerde o
herkesin sığınmak istediği iskandinavya
Kanada gibi ülkelerde Tedirgin olacak
çünkü her an bir kasırga ile karşılaşma
olasılıkları Günden güne artacak kontrol
edilemeyen yangınlar yetersiz beslenme
kitlesel yoksulluk ekonomik krizler
borsaların çalkalanması Peki ne
yapmalıyız artık toplumu politikayı ve
kültürü köklü şekilde değiştirmeye
ihtiyacımız var Kolektif zihniyeti
değiştirmek değerlerde değişim
gerektiriyor Bu da tüketimle ilişkimizi
değiştirmek zorundayız üretilen
ihtiyaçlar ve stati ile ilgili tekrar
düşünmeliyiz artık yeşil ekonomiye
döngüsel ekonomiye geçmeliyiz
doğa ile uyumlu olmalıyız bireysel yarar
ile yarar yerine ortak faydaya
odaklanmalıyız mümkün olan en güçlü
takımı hep birlikte kurmalıyız hepimiz
kendimize sormalıyız bu krizde benim
rolüm ne olacak
ve hareket olmalıyız bir birey olarak
yapabileceğimiz en iyi şey hareket olmak
hareketler elleri sesleri olan
hayallerdir ve bunu hep beraber
gerçekleştireceğiz
Biz neler yaptık biz hep beraber
olduğumuzda iklim ilköğretim de iklim
krizinin müfredatın bir parçası haline
getirdiğinizi düşünün
Doktorlar hemşireler sağlık sistemimizi
bu krize hazırladığımızı düşünün Biz
bunlar için çalışıyoruz hep beraber ve
çok daha fazla hastalık gelecek ve çok
daha etkin bir şekilde kullanmamız
gerekecek
[Müzik]
[Alkış]
sağlıkla anlattık bunu sanatla anlattık
bunu sanatın birleştirici günü Kalplere
dokunup aksiyona geçirme gücü bizlerden
çok daha fazla sporun bütünleştirici
gücü bizlerden çok daha fazla bir
sporcunun ulaşması 5 milyon insana 1
dakikada ulaşması yeterli bir sanatçının
bir şarkıyla 30 milyona ulaşması çok
daha kolay ve bunların Kalbe dokunması
da çok daha kolay
sanatçılarla başladık
[Müzik]
gençleri çocukları bu mücadeleye
liderlik etmelerine neden olduk
kurum kültürlerinin dönüşmesi en önemli
şey değil şirketlerin dönüşümü için
çalışıyoruz ama bunu bilimle yapmalıyız
hep beraber yapmalıyız Çünkü dünya tek
evimiz yegani Yuvamız Gelin bu krizde
hep beraber bir mücadelede hep beraber
olalım bu mücadeleyi hep beraber en iyi
şekilde yapalım çocuklarımız bize yıllar
sonra sorduğunda anne baba sen ne yaptın
bu mücadele için dediklerinde mutlaka
onlara vereceğimiz cevap elimden geleni
yaptım değil her şeyi yaptım olmalı Bunu
ancak beraber başarabiliriz Çok
teşekkürler
[Alkış]